helium comedy club came after the laugh
house was like going through their
problems hidden comedy club came and
they just an amazing comedy club we ran
professionally just gave a new look to
commie and Philadelphia but what he's
talking about with amateur nights every
week the amateur nights were held on
Thursday at helium or this was like a
laugh house God but the winner got $75 I
won the competition for about six to
eight weeks I was under saying I was
winning the competition it was all
amateurs and I was winning but the
reason why I would make sure after each
one I said I don't want to go back and
say the same stuff so the week leading
up to it would be me trying to create
whatever my new jokes were and of course
it's beginning so they're they're green
they're hacky jokes there's nothing
great there's no brilliant material but
my energy my energies to be nuts I would
come on stunts more than today oh my god
I won I would run from the boat I don't
know buddy
Canada my name is little keV the
bastards you don't even say give it up
put a little care of the bass and I've
just run through the doors no way grab
the store now yeah I was talking about a
minute
you couldn't cuz I was so pumped up but
at the time I wasn't Kevin Hart I wasn't
I wasn't being myself I was being a
version of what I thought I should be to
get laughs and that version of me was
getting laughs but it's a character so
it wasn't it's our to figure out that I
didn't have to be a character that I got
really funny